I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The, ladies. Hello. Hey, look at you, lady. Look at me? Yes, I'm looking at you. I'm happy to see your face.
I'm wearing a new shirt. You are. I'm getting into the button downs. Finally, can I just say finally? Why? Because I love a button down. And now you're in the button down club. I am.
It's a wonderful place. Just wait till those flannel button downs come into play. I can't wait. I know. Well, today we're going to talk about the boat. It is season nine, episode six, written by Dan Sterling and directed by John Krasinski. Do you know what the alternate title for this episode was? I'm gonna guess. I don't know, I'm gonna guess.
Ahoy! No. No, not okay. It was Andy's exit. Oh. You know, cause he leaves. He goes away in this episode. Once again, Andy just leaves without giving any notice.
He did this when he went to Florida. What the heck? Yes, and yet he's still the best candidate for manager. I just want to say Darryl's never gone anywhere. No. Darryl has been there. He hasn't started a business with a friend on the side. He isn't also running a beat farm and owning the building.
I mean, I feel like if we could have anyone's complete focus as manager, Darrell is our candidate. And time and time again, he has great ideas. Yep. Well, here is your summary for the boat. Following a series of poor decisions by Mr. Bernard, the Bernard family finances are in ruin. Andy attempts to salvage things by selling the family boat. by Mr. Bernard, the Bernard family finances are in ruin.
Andy attempts to salvage things by selling the family boat. He's very sad though, because he'd always dreamed of sailing it one day. Dwight is tricked into thinking he's being interviewed on the radio. And finally, the burden of keeping Oscars affair with the senator a secret falls squarely on Kevin's shoulders. Kevin of all people.
Mm-hmm. I loved this particular storyline. I loved it so much. All right. Fast fact number one is a location breakdown. We got a fan question from Abby V in Knoxville, Tennessee, who said, We got a fan question from Abby V in Knoxville, Tennessee, who said, where did you film the scenes with Erin and Andy on the boat? Whose boat was it? Please tell us everything.
Well, Abby V, because of Steve Burgess, I've got these answers for you. We shot these scenes in Santa Monica at the Windjammer's Yop Club. We got the boat through our Marine coordinator. He was a guy named Mike George. He was also a friend of our first AD, Kelly Cantley, because, you know, she sails boats.
Yeah. Steve Burgess said that it was so perfect that she was the first AD for this episode. She really helped us with the boat stuff, particularly the parts where the boat had to be moving. So I reached out to Kelly to ask her more specifics about this episode. She was wonderful.
So much detail, you wanna hear it? I do. She said that we scouted a few available boats and we had a very specific criteria. We needed a boat that was big enough where we could shoot down below, but also small enough that Ed could actually sail it by himself, that it would be realistic. Yeah. We also needed it to look luxurious enough for the Bernard family to have owned it. She said we rented a boat from a yacht
broker, and this boat technically could not have been in Andy's family since before he was born, but it was a pretty good match for ones of that time. So I guess a little bit of a cheat there. I wonder if there's some like boat people out there who saw that when they saw the episode. They were like, there's no way that's been in their family that long. That's a new boat. 100% because if you're a boat person, you know everything about boats. That's a new boat. 100% because if you're a boat person, you know everything about boats. Mm-hmm. Kind of like you and trains.
I don't know everything about trains. I just like trains. But let me tell you, the fun person to sit at like a dinner party is someone that like loves boats or trains. Oh, I beg to differ. Are perhaps hummingbirds. I want to sit next to those people. I want to hear all your boat stories.
Okay. Jenna does not. I mean, maybe, maybe, maybe not. You know what? Jenna would do the nod. It's coming up in the whale in the next episode. You would be doing like the Dwight nod. Yes, I am listening.
Mm hmm. It's true. Kelly said this was not the only boat. We were a little bit like speed here. It's not that we had a bunch of different, like main picture boats. We only had that one, but we had a lot of 13 boats. We did not, but we had a lot of support boats. She said we of support boats. She said we had...
Yeah, you know. There's support boats, don't you? Yeah, little support boats. We had two pontoon boats for lighting the dock, and we had two inflatable ribs for camera and crew transfer. We had a seven-person marine crew, a marine coordinator, sailmasters, a lifeguard, and support boat drivers. So it was like a whole second Marine crew to pull off this episode.
Yeah, it was like the main boat in his buddies. Exactly, lady. And you know, of course, there were a ton of safety meetings. Oh, yes. There was a full page safety memo that went out to the cast and crew. It was extensive. It was so detailed, you and I both read it, and some of the things on there cracked me up.
Oh, it's very funny. Wait, I wanna share a few, okay? And then you share some. Okay. So some of these safety measures, Oh, it's very funny. Wait, I want to share a few, okay? And then you share some. Yes. Okay. So some of these safety measures, Jenna, just the way that they were listed and phrased, cracked me up because it reminded me of a memo we might get from like a second grade school teacher on what to do on a field trip.
Yes, so much. Ready? Here were the three that really made me chuckle. Number one. Number one on the list. Use a lot of sunblock. Number two. If you are feeling seasick, please let the medic know. Number three. If you need to throw up, please do so over the side of the boat and not in the boat. Yes. There were so many instructions for what to do should you might vomit.
Well, what was interesting is it was very clear to me from this memo how protective they were of the boat. There were like three different ways that they told you not to ruin the boat. It was like, if you have to throw up, don't throw up in the boat. Throw up on the side of the boat. And then there are a lot of mention of don't scratch the boat.
Clip your radio to your body in such a way that it won't accidentally scratch the boat. Don't wear belt buckles because we don't want to scratch the boat. And I asked Kelly about it. I was like, Kelly, what is with these multiple instructions about not scratching the boat? I was like, Kelly, what is with these multiple instructions about not scratching the boat? And she said that the gel coat and wood trim on a boat is like very susceptible to scratches and dings. And the yacht broker who rented us the boat was watching us
and we didn't wanna have to pay for any repairs. So they were like telling everyone to be super duper, duper careful. Protect the boat. Protect the boat. Protect the boat at all costs, but also wear your sunblock. All right, those are your boat facts, folks. Are you ready for fast fact number two?
Yeah. Okay, there was a super amazing thing that was happening. The week they were scouting this location. So they're out at the dock, they're looking at boats. Mm-hmm. And do you remember this moment in history, Angela? This is like Los Angeles history. The space shuttle Endeavour, which they put on top of a 747 airplane because they were transporting it from Florida to the Los Angeles Science Center
where it was going to be on display. It flew over their heads. So cool, right? Do you remember this? Of course. Everyone in Los Angeles was a buzz about this. You know, the part I remember is how once it landed at the airport, they then had to get it all the way through the busy, narrow streets of Los Angeles to the giant, I don't know what you call it, the giant aircraft hangar where it now sits where you can go with your kids. It was a chaperone for the year my daughter's school went. It was
their trip in first grade and we went and saw the space shuttle and I was a chaperone. It's so so amazing if you're Los Angeles, you have to go see it. But the journey to get it there was so cool. It was so crazy and I completely remember it. I looked it up. They had to temporarily remove or raise up traffic lights. Yes. They had to remove 400 trees along the side of the road to make room. But they pledged to replace each removed tree with four new trees.
So I guess we got 1600 trees in the end. But the thing that I remember is that at the time, my family was living up in the hills and we had a big kitchen window and we had made a makeshift changing station for my son in the kitchen. So if we were upstairs in the house, which is where the kitchen was, we could change him easily.
You know, you do that. Yeah, yeah, sure. So I was changing him on this little changing table and it flew past our window. That's so wild. And I went and I tried to grab my phone, but I didn't get it in time to take a picture, but I was like, oh my God.
You know, you do that. Yeah, yeah, sure. So I was changing him on this little changing table and it flew past our window. That's so wild. And I went and I tried to grab my phone, but I didn't get it in time to take a picture, but I was like, oh my god.
And then of course it was crazy because a couple years later I took him there so that he could see it. Yeah. It's a really great visit if you're in Los Angeles. You know, the other thing is if you go to see the space shuttle, they have this great, I don't know what you call it, like a mini documentary of getting it to the big aircraft hangar, what all it took, what all, and then how people like line the streets to see it. Yeah. And I remember it was like the evening news,
like every day I'd be like, where's it now? Yeah. Get on the TV, where's it now? I totally remember it. Wow, and that was going on during the prep of this episode. All right, moving on to Fast Fact number three, fan question from Logan B in North Carolina, and many other people wrote in about this as well. Logan said, I noticed that Andrew Santino is in this episode. His podcast is so funny, and I would love to hear about his time on the show.
Yes, everybody. The grumpy sailor from the boat. In the big sweater. Yes, is actor and comedian Andrew Santino. He actually has two podcasts. He has Whiskey Ginger, where he interviews friends while they sip whiskey. Hello.
Hello, give us a call. Yeah, up for it. while they sip whiskey. Hello? Yes. Hello, give us a call. Yeah, up for it. And he also has the podcast Bad Friends, which he co-hosts with Bobby Lee, who was my co-star on Splitting Up Together. What? We have a Splitting Up Together crossover.
We do. So I slid into Andrew's DMs. We haven't done that in a while, Ange. Did a little DM slide. I know, I know. And he was kind enough to respond. He sent us audio clips. They're very funny.
I can't wait for you to share them. Of course we had to ask him, how did he get his job on the office? And was he a fan of the show? Here's what he had to say. Alison Jones was a casting director, became a huge fan of mine from all my other failed auditions that I did for her.
And she was like, I think I've got something perfect for you. It's a minimal amount of lines, but you have to look like a sloppy sailor in an oversized sweater. And I said, sign me up. That's perfect. And so, yeah, I did just audition and I got it. And I was extremely excited. It was like the first big job I had ever had
on a massive network television show. And to answer the second question, of course, I was familiar with the show as a massive fan of the show. Being a stand-up comedian, I was a fan of the British office, the OG office. Do I think the American one is better? I don't know, that's not for me to say, but it is. But no, I like them both just the same.
They're both very good, but I was a huge fan. Good ol' Allison Jones, once again, finding us great people. I know. So I had to ask him, since this was one of his first jobs, what was it like for him to show up on set and be directed by John Krasinski and then be in a scene with
this group of actors. Here's what he said. He was extremely mean and rude. He would throw stuff at us in between takes. If you messed up, he would yell at you. He would give you intense stare downs, a very, very mean, rude man, and I will never work with him again. He was wonderful. He was really cool. And I think I told him it was one of my first jobs. So he was really nice about it and Was really easy to work with and Groban was on that one the grobsters So it was cool. It was really fun and he was really nice and easy and to be honest my scene wasn't too complex so smacking at Helms was about the depth of how far I needed to go and
Ellie was cool. Everyone was very nice to me But truly it was such a cool experience to have like that be my first debut on network television. So cool. The Grobstur. Yeah. That's awesome. Is it just me or does it sound like Andrew is driving down the freeway? It does sound like he's in motion. Like I feel like he's running errands, answering our questions. I love it. I love it so much. Well, that's all I got, lady. Do you want to take a break?
I do. And when we come back, I have something to share about some ice cream. Oh, okay. I love an ice cream share. We are back and the first scene is Oscar. He's getting out of his car. It's early in the morning and he asked the camera crew to follow him around back. He says to them, look, I know you saw me with the senator and you know, I think I'm in love possibly for the first time.
And he really hopes that he can count on everyone's discretion. He wants to handle this properly when it's the right time. Yes. Guess who wanders up behind him? It's Kevin and he's having his, I guess, morning ice cream behind the dumpster. His morning mint chocolate chip, which falls on the ground when he hears this news and instantly Oscar's like, oh crap.
He's like, why? Why are you here? Well, of course this made me curious about ice cream in the morning. You know it did. And I've got it according to the internet for you. Oh, and according to the whole internet. I can't wait.
You love these. A study from Kieran University in Tokyo found that eating ice cream in the morning may improve alertness and mental performance. Wait, we need to let that land. Because you have basically just given everyone permission to start their day with ice cream. I know.
I know. Ready? So a professor in his team analyzed the results of multiple clinical trials that measured brain activity after eating various foods in the morning. And according to the study, frozen foods, particularly ice cream, had an awakening effect on the brain. As a result, study subjects showed higher alertness and quicker response. At the same time, ice cream stimulated high-frequency alpha waves
that serve as connectors between conscious thinking and subconscious mind and is responsible for calmness and relaxation. Consequently, the study subjects showed less mental irritability. It's like better than a cup of coffee in the morning, it sounds like. Get up, have your bowl of ice cream. It's going to wake you up. It's going to put you in a good mood. It's going to make you alert.
I'm so sorry. Why has this study not been more widely publicized? And who knew that Kevin was on to something? This is making me want to go eat some ice cream. I know. Thank you for that, according to the Internet. Angela, I absolutely loved it. You're welcome.
You're welcome. Well, this episode is going to open with Andy. He's in a meeting with some financial advisors. They're dealing with his family's financial crisis. Yeah, and he's doing a good job. He's like sort of like giving them orders. He's very direct, very focused. This cuts to a gym and Pam talking head where they share that Andy's family is kind of in a meltdown. His dad spent all their money, fled to Argentina with a younger woman, his brother locked himself in the wine cellar, and here's the weirdest part.
Andy is kind of crushing it. Yeah. Andy has a talking head where he says, yeah, the Nards are hurting, the family is shattered, he's doing damage control. Only thing is he wishes dad could see him. But you know what? His dad caused this, so eff him. Yeah, that's right. Nards are hurting is such a great phrase.
Like I feel like I wanna say it, like when I get up in the morning and I'm feeling a little creaky, like my nards are hurting. Can I say that? Yeah, it works. It works, right? You can just go have a bowl of ice cream and then your nards will be better. Yeah, my nards are hurting. I need some ice cream.
I thought this might be a good time to give you a weather report. Sure. There's never a bad time. I'm on fire today. I'm like, according to the internet, weather report. All right. The week we filmed this episode, the high onset, which you know was in Van Nuys, California, was 100 degrees for multiple days in a row, triple digits. Wow. But the day we filmed the boat scenes in Santa Monica and Marina del Rey, the high was 77 degrees. That's why people live by the beach.
I know. For reference, from our set, door to door, I did a Google map. Okay. From Van Nuys to Marina Del Rey, it's only 21.9 miles, but look at that temperature drop. I know, yeah. I know. Also, little something from the call sheet.
Remember when we did work bus and they put the little bus like graphics on all the little call sheets? Yeah. On these call sheets, we have a little sailboat and some whales. See, I love when they did that stuff on the call sheets. I do too. Just getting creative, getting a little crafty.
Yeah. Given some little icons, what do you call those? Little cartoons. Little cartoons. Everybody loves a cartoon. And these were in color. What? Yeah. They were just, the cartoon was in color. The bus was black and white, but these guys were in color. What? Yeah, they were just the cartoon was in color. The bus was black and white, but these guys were in color.
Little blue whale, little sailboat, I'll have to put them in stories. Well, now we're gonna go to our secret stairwell. This is where all of our most private conversations occur. Mm-hmm, it's the secret stairwell. The secret stairwell. That's why we talk about secrets. I loved Oscar in the scene.
Oscar is phenomenal in this whole episode. He's so good. Brian too. So good. The two of them, yeah. I love this pairing. Oscar is just pleading with Kevin, trying to reason with Kevin about this new knowledge that he has about the affair. Please, please
keep it to yourself, Kevin. He says, I'm in love with the senator. Yeah. And I need time to sort this out in a responsible matter. And he says, it means the world to me, okay? And then I loved Brian's performance as Kevin. He says, that's beautiful. No, I totally get that. And then Oscar says, can you do this, Kevin? And Kevin says, I really want to. Whatever happens, always remember that. Oh, Oscar's in trouble. I know. Now we're about to start a new storyline that I absolutely loved. And Jenna, I don't know about you,
but this episode, the next one, they're really reminding me of early days in the office where there's some Dwight pranking, there's something happening over at accounting. It's like everybody, there's like lots of fun little storylines that remind me of the early days. Yeah, I love all of these little pairings that we're gonna be getting in these episodes coming up.
Yeah, it had a little office Olympics to it, maybe. Yes, yes, exactly. Uh-huh. So what's going on is Pam is gonna get a phone call from the local radio station stating that Iris Black, host of the show BizWiz, wants to interview someone from Dunder Mifflin on air today. Dwight is so excited,
because Pam's like, who wants to talk to Iris? Here's what Dwight says. I want you to hear it, because hear me out, folks. I think it could be a great ringtone. Maybe, maybe we need to make this a ringtone. Can you play it for me, Sam? Sam If I'm like at the grocery store and all of a sudden my phone goes off and you just hear, I do, I do, I do. Come on.
Well Dwight has a talking head where he explains that he's volunteering because this radio appearance could make him famous and it's a lot easier to sell paper when you're famous. That's what's motivating him. Imagine all the paper Brad Pitt could sell. Yeah. Hi, it's Brad Pitt. Do you want some paper? Yes, I do. Yes. I mean,
I would probably buy paper from Brad Pitt. I mean, you know, if Keanu Reeves sold paper, I'd buy it. Well, there's your number one paper salesman right there. Come on. Come on, number one paper salesman. Meredith is now going to approach Andy. You know, she heard about his good-looking single brother that's in a downward spiral with booze. Andy's like, you know what, he's in rehab. And then Meredith starts to flirt with Andy. And Andy's like, we're done here. Yeah. Meredith is trying to hit people when they're at their lowest. Yeah. Meanwhile, Dwight is annoying everyone with his preparation. For his interview, he's doing his speech
exercises, his tongue twisters. Mm-hmm. I think we should hear it. Brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr,
brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr So I remember when we did the table read for this, this tongue twister was in the table read and Rain nailed it. And then when we did it, when we were shooting it, he nailed it. And I was like, Rain, how are you doing that so well? That's why I wanted to play the clip because Rain is so good at these tongue twisters. He said, Jenna, we did these in like theater school. He's like, I know all of them. I can do all of them.
Not only does Rainn say the one that we just heard, but as he's walking out, he says, Trisky Siskel flicked a biscuit in Nikki's sixes sticky whiskers. Yeah, and he says it perfectly. Yeah, as if it's nothing. I know. Well, this of course made me curious
about tongue twisters, y'all. Does the internet have something to say about that? Yeah, the internet does. I'm calling these, wait for it, tongue twister tidbits. I can't wait. Come on, who was on a roll? I don't know, but that's what she said. Okay. Okay, did you know that every year on the second Sunday in November, it is International Tongue Twister Day?
I did not. How do you celebrate? I'm glad you said that because they encourage you to celebrate this day and try some new tongue twisters. And let me tell you, there's lots of them on the internet. Here's another tongue twister tidbit. They were very popular in the 19th century, and the first book of Tongue Twisters was titled... are you ready for it? Okay. Peter Piper's Practical Principles of Plain and Perfect Pronunciation. Oh my god, I couldn't do it! I bet Rain could do it. Peter... okay. Peter Piper's Practical Principles of Plain and Perfect Pronunciation.
Wow. It was published by John Harris in 1813. It contained a tongue twister for each letter of the alphabet on the model of Peter Piper pick-to-peck of pickled peppers. I'm not done. Here's my last tongue twister tidbit. You might wonder out there as you're listening, what is the most difficult tongue twister? Well, in 1974, and it was the last year the Guinness World Records tracked tongue twisters,
the phrase that was deemed the most difficult to say, oh boy, was the sixth sick sheik's sith. What are these words? I can't do it. Damn it. Sixth. Sheeks. The sixth. Sick. I'm going to, you get to say it.
You know what? You get to say this one. Okay. The sixth. Sick sheiks. Sixth. Sheeps. Sick.
Hey, you're so good. So the sheik, the sixth one is sick. Sick and so is his six sheep. They're both sick. They're both sick. And then more recently in 2013, according to speech communications scientist from MIT, the most difficult tongue twister is
Pad Kid Poord Curd Pulled Cod, which that one I have no problem with, which is interesting. I don't even know what that means. I don't know what it means either. So that tongue twister wasn't difficult for me to say, and I was curious, why was one harder for me than the other? And that led me to an interesting study on the science
of why tongue twisters are difficult to say. I'm sorry, before you go on, I just have to say it. What? Is this a study that we needed like, you know. Like in the world? In the world, like of all the studies we can do. And listen, I am super interested in studies. I love a study. Okay. But I guess I'm just wondering, you know what I mean? Like, could you get rid of my cat
allergy first? Okay, fine. The part of it that was interesting to me is that they studied the neural codes and how your brain, you know, identifies speech and the muscles that need to move your mouth and jaw to form words. And basically, tongue twisters are hard because the representations in your brain greatly overlap. And I thought that was interesting. I take it back everything I just said about the study. This sounds very important in the world of like speech, speech impediments, speech development. Yes. And just learning how your brain translates speech. It's fascinating, actually, Jenna.
But there you go. Those are my tongue twister tidbits for you. Well, Angela, I actually, I take it back. Everything about that study seems very important. It's about speech. It's about how speech works in your brain. I stand corrected. I mean, I loved it. I was riveted by it, Jenna. Riveted. I'm sorry I poopooed the study. It's okay. You can un-poo-poo it. I un-poo-poo it. Okay. Now, Andy is in the conference room with Aaron, Oscar, and Daryl. they were reviewing all of the assets that his father couldn't steal and are trying to figure out what to sell to take care of his mom. Yeah.
And you know what? If he sold the boat to this potential buyer, it could cover the purchase of a condo and some living expenses, but Andy's like, no, too many memories. Yeah. What if we sold everything but the boat? Right. But that would only give her about six months of income. Mm-hmm.
Andy did have a speech about the boat that was deleted. It's in the shooting draft and we learned the boat's name. Oh. I thought I would share it. Please. Andy says, it's our sailboat, the Fancy Free, a historic Boston whaler, L class. Well, it's very interesting that he says the name of the boat is
the fancy free, because at the end of the episode, when it's sailing away, it has a completely different name. It's called the Aspire 2. Probably because that was the actual boat name and we couldn't touch it. Well, Andy says in this scene that the boat is a 43 foot tartan sloop. We rented this exact boat, a 43 foot tartan sloop. I didn't know what that was, so I looked it up.
It is considered a medium size yacht. It's just barely medium. Like up to 40 foot is still considered small. So this is at like the low end of medium yachts. Nowadays, the average cost of this boat is around $500,000. Holy moly. Yeah. So I guess that would be a condo and some living expenses.
According to rightboat.com, the price of the boat. Wait, wait, is this in according to the internet? Well, no, this is according to a literal website. That's see, that's the difference, Angela. You often just attribute your facts to the internet without giving like a specific. It would be like if you wrote a bibliography for a school report and you just said according to the library. Well, I often go to multiple websites and I get the consensus. But like the tongue twister thing was nature.com.
That was one spot. Yes. It tickles me that you say according to the internet. According to the internet. Yes. This is according to writeboat.com. See, I didn't look up multiple websites, so I want you to know if you disagree. It's not, this is not an Internet consensus. This is writeboat.com. That's it. They said that the price of this boat can vary depending on the model, the finish, the engines, and they can actually cost as much as a million dollars. You know, Geez.
那是其中一个地方。是的。你说根据互联网上的说法，这让我觉得很好笑。根据互联网上的说法。是的。这是根据 writeboat.com 说的。你看，我没有查阅多个网站，所以我想让你知道，如果你不同意。这不是，这可不是互联网上的共识。这是 writeboat.com。就是这样。他们说这艘船的价格会根据型号、内饰、发动机而有所不同，实际上它们的造价可能高达一百万美元。你知道的，天哪。
Yeah, if you've done it up real nice inside, maybe it's a million. Wowzers. But this website took me down a little bit of a rabbit hole because it listed what is the largest sailing yacht ever in the world? The largest one. Okay, I certainly don't know.
是的，如果你把里面装修得非常漂亮，也许就要一百万美元。哇哦。但这个网站把我带进了一个小小的知识盲区，因为它列出了世界上最大帆船是什么？最大的一艘。好吧，我当然不知道。
It is called Sailing Yacht A. That's the name of it. They couldn't come up with a better name for the biggest boat, the biggest yacht. Sailing Yacht A, I know it's very bland. It cost $600 million. Get out. Does it come with a plane?
它被称为“A”号帆船。这就是它的名字。对于最大的船、最大的游艇，他们居然想不出一个更好的名字。“A”号帆船，我知道这名字很平淡。它造价6亿美元。开玩笑了。它配有飞机吗？
No. What? Not that I saw. It's very secretive. There are very, very few photos of this yacht. There are a few of it from the exterior and almost no interior photos. It's very secret yacht.
没有。什么？我没看到。它非常神秘。关于这艘游艇的照片非常非常少。只有几张它的外观照片，几乎没有内景照片。这是一艘非常神秘的游艇。
It is owned by a Russian billionaire named Andrey Melnichenko. It was designed by Philip Stark and built by a German company. The boat is 470 feet long. It can hold 20 guests and 54 crew members on eight decks. I can't believe this boat is so big, guests and 54 crew members on eight decks. I can't believe this boat is so big, but it only holds 20 guests. Yeah, like what's inside it? Why aren't there pictures of the inside?
它的主人是一位名叫安德烈·梅尔尼琴科的俄罗斯亿万富翁。它由菲利普·斯塔克设计，由一家德国公司建造。这艘船长470英尺。它拥有八层甲板，可容纳20名宾客和54名船员。我真不敢相信这艘船这么大，有宾客和54名船员在八层甲板上。我真不敢相信这艘船这么大，但它只能容纳20位客人。是的，就像里面有什么？为什么没有里面的照片？
What's running up that ticket number? That's on the inside. That's what I wanna know. I know. We should mom detective this. We should mom detective. If we take a little dingy out into the ocean and right, it's going to take a little bit of a road trip for this one. Where how will we board this yacht?
是什么让那张账单金额一直在飙升？就在内部。这就是我想知道的。我知道。我们应该用妈妈侦探的方式来查明这一点。我们应该像妈妈侦探一样。如果我们开着一艘小艇出海，对吧，这趟行程我们要开着车去兜一圈。我们要如何登上这艘游艇？
I don't know. Will we drop in from the air? Will we try to dingy it? What do we do? It's very large. It's very large and it's expensive. I bet it has some anti theft devices that we don't want to encounter. I would think so. It's also like the outside of it. There's very little outdoor area when I was
我不知道。我们会从空中降落吗？我们会试着用小艇靠近吗？我们该怎么办？它非常大。它非常大而且很贵。我敢打赌它有一些我们不想遇到的防盗装置。我也这么觉得。而且就像它的外部一样。当我看到它的照片时，户外区域非常少。
looking at the pictures of it. You're very inside if you're in this boat. And it also like, it kind of looks like a skyscraper. Like it's very smooth. It's like a metal building. So like if you tried to land on it, you would probably just slide off down the side into the water. There's very few opportunities to parachute onto it. For example, if we were thinking of doing that, I don't know. It's a boat bunker. Kind of.
如果你在这艘船里，你基本都在室内。而且它看起来也有点像摩天大楼。它非常光滑。就像一座金属建筑。所以如果你试图降落在上面，你可能只会从侧面滑落到水里。几乎没有什么机会能用降落伞降落在它上面。比方说，如果我们想那样做的话，我不知道。它是一个游艇掩体。某种程度上是这样的。
It has an underwater observation deck. So while you're in it, you can see stuff. I guess. And here's the thing. Its top speed is 21 knots, which is just over 25 miles per hour. That's like a pontoon boat. You're going so slow in it. So slow. My uncle Sonny used to get a pontoon boat. We'd all get on it. We get a pontoon boat and we'd all get on it. We had a pontoon boat growing up.
它有一个水下观景台。所以当你在里面的时候，你可以看到各种东西。我猜是的。还有一件事。它的最高时速是21海里，也就是略高于每小时25英里。那就跟一艘平底船差不多。你在上面开得太慢了。太慢了。我叔叔桑尼以前有一艘平底船。我们全都会上去。我们弄了一艘平底船，然后我们全上去了。我们小时候有一艘平底船。
Yeah, we would rent this one and you go like three miles an hour, it feels like. I love a pontoon boat. I love a pontoon. Next vacation, you and I. A pontoon boat, I would be up for it. Let me tell you, if we like had a little cooler, some snacks, maybe, you know if we like had a little cooler,
是的，我们会租这艘船，感觉你就像是以每小时三英里的速度前进。我很喜欢平底船。我很喜欢平底船。下一个假期，你和我。平底船，我完全愿意。跟你说实话，如果我们带了一个小冷藏箱，带了一些零食，也许，你知道的，如果我们带了一个小冷藏箱，
some snacks, maybe, you know, we're not driving an adult beverage on a pontoon boat on the lake, get out. So fun. So fun. My final fact about this boat, the sailing yacht A, so it costs $600 million to buy it, but it also costs $60 million per year to operate it,
带了一些零食，也许，你知道的，我们不能在湖里的平底船上喝烈性含酒精饮料，开玩笑吧。太有趣了。太有趣了。关于这艘船——“A”号帆船的最后一个事实是，购买它需要6亿美元，但每年的运营成本也高达6000万美元，
like it's operating costs. Which is stupid, that's stupid. Sorry, boat owner. Sorry, Andre. Sorry, Andre. This seems very frivolous to me. I don't know why that tickled me, but it is. It's so unnecessary.
就像它的运营成本一样。这太蠢了，这太蠢了。对不起了，船东。对不起了，安德烈。对不起了，安德烈。在我看来这非常轻浮。我不知道为什么这让我觉得好笑，但它确实如此。这完全没有必要。
What do you need this boat for? I don't understand it. I don't understand anything about this. I don't understand yachting in general. We've talked about this. I know we've talked about this. I don't get what's fun about it. I like to be on a boat, like a speedboat or on the lake or a pontoon boat.
你需要这艘船干什么？我搞不懂。我对这一切都一无所知。我对游艇一无所知。我们讨论过这个。我知道我们讨论过这事。我不明白这有什么好玩的。我喜欢在船上，比如快艇，或者在湖里，或者在平底船上。
Yes, all those things I get. I like boating, but I just don't need to like yacht. Yeah. And you know what? It's a good thing because I can't afford it. So, there we go. Geez, Louise, at those prices. Shall we move on to the next scene? Yes, we are out in the bullpen. Oscar can see Angela and Kevin talking by the copy machine.
是的，所有这些我都能理解。我喜欢划船，但我就是不需要去玩游艇。是的。你知道吗？这其实是件好事，因为我买不起。所以，就这样吧。天哪，罗伊斯，这价格。我们是不是该进入下一个场景了？是的，我们在办公区。奥斯卡看到安吉拉和凯文在复印机旁聊天。
It's jammed. Angela wonders if the day could get any worse, and Kevin's like, oh, it could. It could get a lot worse. Oscar calls over to Kevin. You know, he's just like, Kevin, stop! Mm-hmm. And Kevin pivots. like, Kevin, stop. Mm-hmm. And Kevin pivots.
卡纸了。安吉拉想知道今天还能不能再糟糕一点，凯文则觉得，哦，完全可以。情况可能会糟糕得多。奥斯卡朝凯文喊道。你知道的，他就像是在说，凯文，住手！嗯哼。然后凯文转过身去。就像是，凯文，住手。嗯哼。然后凯文转过身去。
Yeah, Kevin does okay. Angela, we got a fan question from Shaley D in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania, and it is for you. Okay, Shaley, what's up? Shaley says, Angela, your hair looks so pretty in this episode with the half up, half down side braid. Did you like this hairstyle and was it hard for Kim Ferry to do?
是的，凯文做得挺好。安吉拉，我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的谢利·D的一个粉丝提问，这是给你的。好的，谢利，怎么了？谢利说，安吉拉，在这集里，你半扎半放、带有侧边编发的发型看起来太漂亮了。你喜欢这个发型吗？金·费瑞做这个发型很难吗？
Oh, Shaley, I love this question. We got very excited this season about my hair. Basically, I just told Kim I wanna look pretty. I don't want any severe ponytails if possible because I had this fun love triangle story between the senator and Oscar and Kim was great. I know I've shared this before, but Shae Lee, Kim is a fantastic braider. She can do multiple different kinds of braids. You name the braid, she can do it.
哦，谢利，我太喜欢这个问题了。这个季度我们对我的头发感到非常兴奋。基本上，我只是告诉金我想看起来漂亮。如果可能的话，我不要任何扎得很高很紧的马尾辫，因为我和参议员以及奥斯卡之间有一段有趣的三角恋故事，而且金真的很棒。我知道我以前分享过这个，但是谢利，金是一个非常出色的编发师。她能做出多种不同风格的辫子。你只要说得出名字的辫子，她就能编出来。
I also think she invented some braids. Like, she's so good. She's so crafty with the hair. Yeah. But we were talking about some kind of half up, half down situation and she was like, what if I do the braids, you know, on the side and then clip it in the back? And I was like, let's do it. And I love this look. I recently did the same hairstyle for my daughter for a friend's wedding. I love it. I think that this is so perfect because like you said, Angela is now married to the senator. And so I could see her wanting to bump it up a little bit,
我也觉得她发明了一些辫子。真的，她太厉害了。她在美发方面非常有手艺。是的。但我们当时在讨论某种半扎半放的发型，然后她就说，如果我把辫子编在旁边，然后用发夹在后面固定起来，怎么样？然后我就说，那就这么办吧。我太喜欢这个造型了。我最近也为我女儿参加朋友婚礼时做了同样的造型。我很喜欢。我觉得这太完美了，正如你所说，安吉拉现在嫁给参议员了。所以我能看出她想要稍微提升一下自己的形象，
but then the braid is still a nod to the Angela we know. Angela loves these braids. Yeah. It's such a great, great hairstyle. And I noticed your hair in this episode too. It's so cute. Well, thank you, Shaylee. Thank you, Jenna.
但同时编发仍然是对我们所熟知的安吉拉的一种致敬。安吉拉很喜欢这种编发。是的。这真的是一款非常非常棒的发型。而且我注意到这一集里你的发型也很可爱。好吧，谢谢你，谢利。谢谢你，珍娜。
Mm-hmm. Well, ultimately, Andy decides, you know what? We have to sail the boat. He's a little teary about it, but he decides to do it. Yeah. And meanwhile, the radio station calls Pam back and cancels the interview. There's actually this new cupcake place that's opening up at Steamtown Mall and they're going to go cover that instead.
嗯哼。总之，安迪决定，管他呢？我们必须扬帆出海。他对此有点依依不舍，但他还是决定这么做。是的。与此同时，广播电台给帕姆回了电话，取消了采访。史蒂姆敦购物中心实际上有一家新开的纸杯蛋糕店，他们打算改去报道那个。
So Nelly's going to go tell Dwight that the interview is off, but Jim gets a little idea. Mm hmm. A little bit of old Jim happened in here, especially with Pamis has accomplished. They're going to prank Dwight. Yeah. Jim is working on a prank and Erin is working up a way to try and cheer up Andy by putting watermelon teeth.
所以内莉打算去告诉德怀特采访取消了，但吉姆有了一个小主意。嗯哼。一些老吉姆式的恶作剧在这里上演了，特别是考虑到帕姆所取得的成就。他们要捉弄德怀特。岁。吉姆正在筹划一个恶作剧，而艾琳则在想办法通过放上西瓜皮牙齿来让安迪开心起来。
She has, I guess, carved teeth out of like a watermelon rind or something. Is this something people do? I looked it up and like, what is this? Is this a thing? Did you ever do this, Angela? I'd never heard of this. No, no, no. I think this is special for Erin. Okay. All right. She goes on to explain that a girlfriend needs to know how to cheer up her man. And Andy is seriously juvenile. And then Pete has a really funny line where he's like,
她，我猜是用西瓜皮之类东西雕刻出了牙齿的形状。这是人们会做的事吗？我查了一下，然后觉得，这是什么？这算是一回事吗？安吉拉，你以前做过这个吗？我从来没听说过。不，不，不。我觉得这是艾琳特有的举动。好吧。好吧。她接着解释说，女朋友需要知道如何哄自己的男人开心。而安吉拉简直幼稚得要命。然后皮特有一句非常搞笑的台词，他说，
but he's like 40, right? Yeah. And Erin doesn't know how old he is. Yeah. She's not sure. Well, unfortunately, when she walks into Andy's office, he is not amused. He had no reaction. It did not work. Well, next up, we're going to move to this radio show prank. But should we take a break first and then we can really get into it?
但他已经快40岁了吧？是的。而且艾琳不知道他到底多大。是的。她不太确定。嗯，不幸的是，当她走进安迪的办公室时，他一点也高兴不起来。他没有任何反应。这根本没起作用。好了，接下来，我们要进入这个广播节目恶作剧。但我们是不是应该先休息一下，然后才能真正深入其中？
Yes. Because when we come back, I have a fun moment between Dwight and Stanley and a deleted Stanley talking head. Woohoo! Music We are back and Dwight is about to get all set up in the break room ready for his interview. But right before he does, there's a fun moment between Dwight and Stanley that got deleted. Stanley says, hey Dwight, be sure and tell Iris I said hello. Like what? And then it cuts to a Stanley talking head.
是的。因为当我们回来时，我将带来一个德怀特和斯坦利之间的有趣时刻，以及一段被剪掉的斯坦利的采访独白。呼！音乐 我们回来了，德怀特正准备在休息室里为他的采访做好一切准备。但就在他开始之前，德怀特和斯坦利之间发生了一个被删掉的有趣时刻。斯坦利说：“嘿，德怀特，务必替我向艾里斯问好。”简直莫名其妙！然后镜头切到了斯坦利的采访独白。
Apparently Stanley really likes Iris. Let's hear it. Iris Black has not responded to one of my fan letters, but I know that she reads them. If you're watching this, Iris, I'm your number one fan. I remember this. Yeah. I remember it got a big laugh at the table read.
显然斯坦利真的很喜欢艾里斯。我们听听看。艾里斯·布莱克没有回复我的任何一封粉丝信，但我知道她读过这些信。如果你在看这个，艾里斯，我是你的头号粉丝。我记得这个。是的。我记得在围读剧本的时候，这引发了一场大笑。
Yeah. And Leslie really commits. He leans in. He's like, I'm your number one fan. Anyway, it just tickled me and I wanted to share it because I love when we pill back a little layer on a character and now we all know that Stanley loves Iris Black. Well, in the conference room, we have our little fakey radio show going. Darrell is on his keyboard and Nelly and Pam and Jim are all around the conference table and it's time.
是的。而且莱斯利真的很投入。他身体前倾。他说：“我是你的头号粉丝。”总之，这只是让我觉得很有趣，我想把它分享出来，因为我喜欢我们剥开角色身上的那一小层伪装，现在我们都知道斯坦利深爱着艾里斯·布莱克。好吧，在会议室里，我们的小型虚假广播节目正在进行。达雷尔在弹奏他的键盘，内莉、帕姆和吉姆都围坐在会议桌旁，时间到了。
It's showtime. Iris Black welcomes Dwight to BizWiz. And Catherine Tate does such a great job as this character, Miss Black. I wanted to point out at five minutes and 51 seconds, I do not have my pink coffee mug anymore. Remember I said it broke during season nine? Oh. I think it was this episode
节目开始了。艾里斯·布莱克欢迎德怀特来到“BizWiz”。凯瑟琳·塔特饰演的布莱克女士这个角色表现得太棒了。我想指出的是，在5分51秒的时候，我不再拿着我那个粉红色的咖啡杯了。还记得我说过它在第九季中摔碎了吗？哦。我想就是这一集，
and I'm gonna start having this new purple coffee mug. We're gonna have to track it. Mm-hmm. We got a fan question from Alyssa H in Mountain Home, Arkansas who said, "'This is hands down one of my favorite scenes in the whole show and I'd love to hear about how this scene came out and everything about it.'
我将开始使用这个新的紫色咖啡杯。我们得追踪一下它。嗯哼。我们收到了来自阿肯色州山家镇的阿莉莎·H的一个粉丝提问，她说：“毫无疑问，这是整部剧中我最喜欢的场景之一，我很想听听这个场景是怎么拍出来的，以及关于它的一切。”
And Juliana S from Tallahassee, Florida Florida said, in the group prank on Dwight, were you guys having phone calls off camera or strictly filming one side of the conversation? Well, I'll tell you guys, this was so complicated to shoot because we shot these scenes at the same time. We hired extra camera operators and we had one crew back in the break room with Dwight. We had another crew with us in the conference room. This was all live. We filmed both sides at the same time. But John Krasinski, who was in the conference room,
来自佛罗里达州塔拉哈西的朱莉安娜·S说：“在集体捉弄德怀特的过程中，你们是在镜头外打电话，还是严格只拍摄对话的一方？”好吧，我告诉你们，拍摄这个过程太复杂了，因为我们是同时拍摄这些场景的。我们雇用了额外的摄像师，一组工作人员在休息室陪着德怀特，另一组工作人员和我们一起在会议室里。这都是现场直播。我们同时拍摄了双方。但是吉姆的扮演者约翰·卡拉辛斯基，他当时也在会议室里，
was directing this episode. So after we would do a couple of takes, we would have to stop so that John could watch the playback of what happened back in the break room. It was so complicated, but so smart because this allowed you guys to react in the moment to anything spontaneous. Nothing felt contrived. It's all feeling so organic and fun. And it's one of the things I love about our show. Same. Agree. So skipping ahead a little bit as this radio interview continues, Iris Black
他正在导演这一集。所以当我们拍完几条之后，我们不得不停下来，以便约翰观看休息室里发生的事情的回放。这太复杂了，但也太聪明了，因为这让你们能够针对任何自发的情况做出当下的反应。没有任何东西显得矫揉造作。一切都感觉那么自然、有趣。这也是我喜欢我们这部剧的原因之一。我也是。完全同意。所以随着广播采访的继续，我们稍微快进一点，艾里斯·布莱克
manages to get Dwight to start throwing some shade at David Wallace, the CEO. Dwight doesn't mean to. And then they have a very funny bit where Steve, AKA Jim, the sound engineer says, you know what, we hear this clinking sound. I think it's from the buttons on your shirt. You're going to have to take that off. Yeah. And then they say, are you wearing pants with a metal zipper?
设法引导德怀特开始对首席执行官大卫·华莱士冷嘲热讽。德怀特其实并非有意如此。然后他们有一段非常搞笑的对话，史蒂夫（也就是吉姆，音响工程师）说：“你知道吗，我们听到这种叮叮当当的声音。我猜是你的衬衫纽扣发出的。你得把它脱掉。”是的。然后他们说：“你穿的裤子带有金属拉链吗？”
Maybe you should take those off. And Dwight, of course, being Dwight doesn't question it. Now he's removing his clothing for this interview. Yeah. I want you to know, there's a lot of gesturing and whispering between us during this scene, where we're pranking Dwight. All of those little moments were scripted.
也许你应该把它脱掉。而德怀特，作为德怀特，当然不会质疑。现在他为了这次采访正在脱衣服。是的。我想让你们知道，在这个捉弄德怀特的场景中，我们之间有大量的肢体语言和窃窃私语。所有那些微小的时刻都是剧本写好的。
Everything, like Pam looking at Jim and being like, no, it's too much, no. Or like the thumbs up or the thumbs down. All of that was meticulously listed in the script. You guys though crush it because it feels just so in the moment. Well, back in accounting, Kevin failed to order more 1188 forms, which really disappoints Angela. And she says, I don't know why I'm surprised. Nothing he could do could ever surprise me anymore. Kevin finds this very funny. He thinks, oh yeah, I could surprise you. Oscar starts to panic. Oscar actually makes this noise.
一切，比如帕姆看着吉姆，好像在说，不，这太过分了，不。或者竖起大拇指或倒竖大拇指。所有这些都在剧本中被一丝不苟地列出来了。不过你们演得太棒了，因为感觉完全就是当下的真实反应。好吧，镜头回到会计部，凯文没能订购更多1188表格，这让安吉拉非常失望。她说：“我不知道自己为什么还要惊讶。他做的任何事都不会再让我感到意外了。”凯文觉得这非常搞笑。他心想，哦，是的，我能让你大吃一惊。奥斯卡开始惊慌失措。奥斯卡甚至发出了这样的声音。
He's like, ha! And then Kevin goes, I've gotta go to the bathroom. And he like runs out of there. Yeah, Oscar explains that's actually not a bad cover story. You'd be surprised how often Kevin rushes out of the room to go to the bathroom. And then there's a very funny montage where Kevin is just rushing to the bathroom
他喊道：“哈！”然后凯文说：“我得去趟洗手间。”然后他就像一阵风似地跑出去了。是的，奥斯卡解释说这其实不是一个糟糕的借口。你会惊讶于凯文冲出房间去洗手间的频率有多高。然后有一个非常搞笑的蒙太奇片段，凯文在会议室中间
in the middle of a conference room when the elevator door is open. My favorite is when he's running through the parking lot kind of holding his tush. It just reminds me of a toddler. These montages are very funny and we do them sometimes on the show. They are so tedious because every one of those little pops is a different wardrobe change. It's maybe a different hairstyle. Yeah. Yes.
电梯门打开的时候，正匆忙赶往洗手间。我最喜欢的是他穿过停车场时，双手护着屁股的样子。这让我想起了学步的小孩。这些蒙太奇片段非常搞笑，我们有时在节目中也会这样做。它们太繁琐了，因为每一个这样的小片段都意味着更换不同的服装。可能还要换个发型。是的。是的。
Like that little four seconds of montage took half a day. Yep. Well, all of this is going on. Erin is still trying to cheer up Andy. And there was a scene between Erin and Pete. It's very cute and flirty. And it sort of sets up Aaron's motivation to go invite Andy to go visit the boat and have lunch. Was this Pete's idea? You gotta hear it. Okay.
就像那四秒钟的蒙太奇就花了半天时间。是的。这一切都在发生的时候，艾琳仍在试图让安迪开心起来。艾琳和皮特之间有一场戏。非常可爱，而且带着调情意味。这在某种程度上为艾琳邀请安迪去参观游艇并共进午餐的动机做了铺垫。这真的是皮特的 主意吗？你们得听听看。好吧。
Hey, I need to tell you a secret. Oh, my job is not very demanding. My job is not very demanding. Shhh. Keep it down. Listen, if you ever have an emergency or you need to take a depressed boyfriend out to the lounge or something, let me know. I'll cover the phones for you. Shhh. That is so nice of you.
嘿，我得告诉你一个秘密。哦，我的工作要求不高。我的工作要求不高。嘘。小声点。听着，如果你遇到什么紧急情况，或者你需要带一个情绪低落的男朋友去休息室散心什么的，告诉我。我帮你接听电话。嘘。你太好了。
But do you know how to use the phone system? Are you kidding me? No. Check me out. Let's get in here. Do you know how to use the phone system? Are you kidding me? Check me out. Let's get in here. Dunder Mifflin, this is Pete. Very good. But what if you have to take a phone message?
但你知道怎么使用电话系统吗？你在开玩笑吗？没有。看着我。我们来这儿。你知道怎么使用电话系统吗？你在开玩笑吗？看着我。我们来这儿。这里是邓德米弗林，我是皮特。非常好。但如果你需要接听电话留言呢？
Lay it on me. Take a pen, take a piece of paper, write down the message. Oh, I think there's someone else think there's someone on the phone. Don't remember if this is Aaron. It was really sweet when he says, oh yeah, I got this. He picks up the wrong phone,
尽管说吧。拿支笔，拿张纸，把留言写下来。哦，我觉得还有别人——我觉得有人在打电话。不记得这到底是不是艾琳。当他说“哦，是的，我搞定了”时，真的很甜蜜。他接错了电话，
is writing on the wrong thing, and then she is showing him how to write a note, but then there's an actual person calling and on the phone. Yeah, yeah. But it's really cute. But he's there for her. He's like, if you need to go cheer up Andy, I'll cover you. Well, unfortunately, Andy's not interested.
而且在错误的东西上写字，接着她正在教他怎么写便条，但实际上当时有个人正在打电话。对的，对的。但这真的很可爱。不过他一直在支持她。他说：“如果你需要去哄安迪开心，我来替你顶着。”好吧，不幸的是，安迪并不感兴趣。
Yeah. But then Aaron has an idea he is interested in. Why don't we go sail that boat one time before you give it up? I don't care that it's in Stamford, Connecticut. We got to leave right now. But let's do it. Andy is so excited. I think it's in Stanford, Connecticut. We gotta leave right now, but let's do it. Andy is so excited. I think it's a sweet idea. I do too. To go say goodbye to the boat. Yeah.
是的。但随后艾琳想出了一个他感兴趣的主意。为什么我们在你放弃这艘船之前，不去开着它航行一次呢？我才不在乎它是在康涅狄格州的斯坦福。我们得马上离开。但我们干吧。安吉拉，安迪太兴奋了。我觉得它在康涅狄格州的斯坦福。我们得马上离开，但我们干吧。安迪太兴奋了。我觉得这是个甜蜜的主意。我也这么觉得。去跟那艘船告别。是的。
That's an important ritual. I think so. Well, the next scene might be the final straw for Kevin. Angela gets off the phone with the senator and says, oh, the senator's exhausted from the campaign. He's up against a man who's so dirty and the senator keeps pushing back as hard as he can. Kevin's like, you have to stop.
这是一个重要的仪式。我也这么认为。好吧，接下来的场景可能是压垮凯文的最后一根稻草。安吉拉挂断了参议员的电话，说道：“哦，参议员累坏了，为了竞选活动。他的对手是个非常卑鄙的家伙，参议员一直在尽其所能地全力反击。”凯文说：“你得停下来。”
And then Angela says, last night, he was so tired, he just wanted a little Mexican brought in. Kevin is hysterical. It's too much for him, he leaves. I thought this scene was very funny, but I was a little bit distracted. Angela, we have a new local mug report. Oh, Kevin has a mug on his desk from Acre Drill Company. It was founded in 1916. And they're one of North America's largest
然后安吉拉说：“昨晚，他累极了，只想让人送点墨西哥菜来。”凯文歇斯底里了。这对他来说太过分了，他离开了。我觉得这个场景非常搞笑，但我有点分心了。安吉拉，我们有一个新的当地马克杯报告。哦，凯文的桌子上有一个来自Acre钻井公司的马克杯。它成立于1916年。他们是北美最大的
manufacturers of drilling equipment worldwide. New local mug report. There you go. I had my eyes open for the mugs on this episode. Clearly, they were speaking to you. Yep. Well, right after Kevin rushes off, Oscar has a talking head where he says, I'm in big trouble.
钻探设备制造商之一，业务遍及全球。全新的当地马克杯报告。给你。我一直留意着这一集里的马克杯。很显然，它们在对你说话。是的。就在凯文冲出去之后，奥斯卡做了一个采访独白，他说：“我摊上大麻烦了。”
And then Kevin has a talking head where he says, Oscar's in big trouble. And Oscar's gonna do something very unethical. He's got this folder. A sabotage folder. Yes. It has, I guess, information about Kevin not doing his job well. He's going to take it back to Toby.
然后凯文做了一个采访独白，他说：“奥斯卡摊上大麻烦了。”而奥斯卡要做一件非常不道德的事情。他拿着这个文件夹。一个蓄意破坏的文件夹。是的。我想这里面有关于凯文工作做不好的信息。他要把这个拿回给托比。
And we had a fan question from Jasmine B. In Southern Manitoba, Jasmine said, why does Toby start wearing glasses all of a sudden? He continues to wear glasses for a time after this episode. Was this intentional or did Paul just start wearing glasses and nobody cared? Jasmine, correct. Paul needed to start wearing glasses, so we just put him on Toby. We never discuss it. It just happened.
我们收到了来自马尼托巴省南部的茉莉·B的粉丝提问，茉莉问：“为什么托比突然开始戴眼镜了？在这集之后的一段时间里他一直戴着眼镜。这是刻意安排的，还是保罗（托比扮演者）只是开始戴眼镜了，然后没人介意？”茉莉，你说得对。保罗需要开始戴眼镜了，所以我们就把它安在了托比身上。我们从来没有讨论过这件事。它就这么发生了。
Paul had always had glasses, and I think he just decided to start wearing them. Yeah, I think it kind of tracks, though. I could see Toby as a character suddenly coming into the office with glasses and not a single person mentioning it. Yeah. So, I think it's very realistic that we never refer to these sudden glasses. Well, as Toby analyzes this Kevin folder, he's like, wow, Kevin's gambling problem has resurfaced.
保罗一直都有眼镜，我想他只是决定开始戴了。是的，不过我觉得这挺合情理的。我能想象托比这个角色突然戴着眼镜走进办公室，而没有一个人提起这件事。是的。所以，我们从不提及这突如其来的眼镜，我觉得这非常现实。好吧，当托比分析这个关于凯文的文件夹时，他心想：“哇，凯文的赌博问题又死灰复燃了。”
You know what? I'm going to have to send Kevin home until I can investigate further. So Toby summons Kevin. Mm-hmm. Kevin's actually excited. He thinks he's getting a promotion. I can investigate further. So Toby summons Kevin. Kevin's actually excited. He thinks he's getting a promotion. I know, I know. Oscar feels bad. Yeah.
你知道吗？我得送凯文回家，直到我能进一步调查清楚。于是托比把凯文叫了过去。嗯哼。凯文其实很兴奋。他以为自己要升职了。我能进一步调查清楚。于是托比把凯文叫了过去。凯文其实很兴奋。他以为自己要升职了。我知道，我知道。奥斯卡觉得很内疚。是的。
We had a fan catch from Ashley S. in California who said at 11 minutes and 14 seconds, Oscar has a yellow sunburst sticker on his side of the partition between Kevin and Angela's desks. It's right above a framed portrait of a dog. Is that sticker from Tobin James Sellers? It is a winery in Paso Robles, California, and it looks identical to their logo.
我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州的阿什利·S的粉丝抓包，她说在11分14秒时，在凯文和安吉拉办公桌之间的隔断上，奥斯卡的这一侧贴着一个黄色的太阳爆发贴纸。它就在一幅装裱好的狗狗肖像上方。这个贴纸是来自加州帕索罗布尔斯的托宾·詹姆斯酒庄吗？它看起来和他们的标志一模一样。
I live in Paso Robles and was so excited to see it. Well, Ashley, I did a little side by side. Oh, I love a side by side. I know I love a side by side as well. Angela, I think Ashley is correct. What do you think? Oh, yeah. Right?
我住在帕索罗布尔斯，看到它时太兴奋了。好吧，阿什利，我做了一个对比图。哦，我太喜欢对比图了。我知道我也很喜欢对比图。安吉拉，我觉得阿什利是对的。你觉得呢？哦，是的。对吧？
My theory is that Oscar Nunez put that there. That me too. Because that is a framedz put that there. That me too. Me too. That is a framed photo of his dog. Mm-hmm. And maybe he went my tasting. He just put the sticker there when he got to work. Great catch, Ashley.
我的理论是奥斯卡·努涅斯把那个贴在那里的。我也是这么想。我也是。那是一张他狗狗的装裱照片。嗯哼。也许他去参加了品酒会。他上班时顺手就把贴纸贴在那儿了。好眼力，阿什利。
When Toby is speaking to Kevin, he is quickly interrupted by Oscar, who gives Kevin some money to go get something out of the vending machine. And he fesses up to Toby that it's not true. It's just not true. He falsified the numbers and he did it. He set him up because he was annoyed. They had an argument. He was trying to get back at him.
当托比正在和凯文说话时，奥斯卡迅速打断了他，奥斯卡给了凯文一些钱让他去自动售货机买点东西。然后他向托比坦白说这一切都不是真的。这完全不是真的。他伪造了数据，而且是他干的。他陷害凯文是因为他很恼火。他们吵过架。他当时想报复凯文。
You know what? It doesn't even matter what Oscar's saying to Toby about Kevin because all Toby's doing is thinking back to that case with the Scranton Strangler. He's like, oh no, I suspected this all along. A few years ago when I was on the Scranton Strangler jury, I thought he had been set up. I felt pressured to convict.
你知道吗？奥斯卡对托比说关于凯文的什么甚至都不重要，因为托比满脑子想的都是斯克兰顿扼喉杀手那个案子。他心想：“哦，不，我一直都在怀疑这一点。几年前我在斯克兰顿扼喉杀手案陪审团时，我就觉得他是被陷害的。我感到了定罪的压力。”
I put away an innocent man. He's not even really listening to what Oscar is saying. No, he heard the word set up and it triggered. It just triggered this fear that the Scranton Strangler was actually set up and that he convicted the wrong person. And here he almost did it again, right? He almost convicted Kevin of a false crime.
“我把一个无辜的人关进去了。”他根本没有真正在听奥斯卡在说些什么。不，他听到了“陷害”这个词，这触发了连锁反应。这只是触发了这样一种恐惧，即斯克兰顿扼喉杀手实际上是被陷害的，而他给错误的人定罪了。而且在这里他差点又做了一次，对吧？他差点给凯文安上一个莫须有的罪名。
Yeah. He can't let this keep happening in his life. Listen, lady, if you thought I was only going to track two mugs in this episode, I've got news for you. Another mug? Yes, this time it is with the help of Shelby P. from Louisville, Kentucky, who said, when Oscar comes back to Toby's desk, there is a yellow NBC mug on Toby's desk. It's very clearly in the shot.
是的。他不能让这种事继续在他的生活中发生了。听着，女士，如果你以为我在这集里只会追踪两个马克杯，那我可要告诉你个消息了。又一个马克杯？是的，这次是在肯塔基州路易斯安那市的谢尔比·P的帮助下找到的，她说：“当奥斯卡回到托比的桌子旁时，托比的桌子上有一个黄色的NBC马克杯。它非常清晰地出现在镜头里。”
Did Paul leave this there by mistake? Or was this an on-purpose nod to NBC? Well, Shelby, it was an NBC mug, but it was for the local Scranton Station of NBC, WBRE. I love a local station, shout out. And we also got this tidbit, Ang, from Jessica J. in St. Paul, Minnesota, who said, I just want to say that I'm mad at Oscar for being willing to get Kevin fired in order to keep his own betrayal a secret. And when he came clean to Toby, he didn't even get in trouble for it. Jessica, I kind of thought the same thing.
是保罗不小心把它忘在那里的吗？还是这是对NBC的一种刻意致敬？好吧，谢尔比，这确实是一个NBC的马克杯，但它是为NBC当地的斯克兰顿分台WBRE准备的。我喜欢当地电视台，向他们致敬。安吉，我们还从明尼苏达州圣保罗市的杰西卡·J那里得到了这样一条趣闻，她说：“我只想说我很生奥斯卡的气，为了掩盖他自己的背叛行为，他竟然愿意让凯文被解雇。而当他向托比坦白时，他甚至没有因此惹上麻烦。”杰西卡，我其实也有同感。
But Toby is spinning out about the Scranton Strangler. Exactly. Toby's in his head about his own stuff. And so Oscar skates free on this one. Here's my question. And this is, I'm going to open up a convo about it. A conflab. Conflab? What's a conflab? It's like a conversation where you discuss something. It's from that TV show, Glow Up.
但托比正因为斯克兰顿扼喉杀手的事情而心烦意乱。没错。托比满脑子都在想他自己的事。所以奥斯卡在这件事上侥幸过关了。我的问题是这样的。而且这是——我要就此展开一场对话。一场密谈。密谈？什么是密谈？就像是一场讨论某事的对话。这是那个英国电视节目《化妆界新星》（Glow Up）里的词。
It's the makeup challenge show from England. They have a conflab. Oh, a flabby convo. Let's go. Yeah, okay. So here's my conflab. Do you think that Oscar fabricated the numbers in that folder or do you think that they were real?
那是来自英国的美妆挑战节目。他们会进行密谈。哦，一场随意的对话。我们开始吧。好吧，那么我的密谈来了。你觉得是奥斯卡捏造了那个文件夹里的数字，还是你觉得它们是真的？
Because I think he really has been keeping a folder on Kevin, maybe in case he ever needed to defend himself or the company against some sort of, I don't know. You know what I mean? Oh. And he handed, I don't think he'd like sat down and made this up. I think this is a secret file folder that Oscar has been keeping.
因为我觉得他确实一直在保留一份关于凯文的文件夹，也许是为了以防他以后需要保护自己或公司免受某种，我不知道。你知道我的意思吗？哦。而且他递过去的文件，我不认为是他坐下来凭空捏造出来的。我觉得这是一份奥斯卡一直保留的秘密档案夹。
100%. Oscar is a great accountant. He's seen all the discrepancies on Kevin's side of the desk, and he's been keeping tabs to cover his own ass and has that folder ready to play it when he needs it, but he never thought he would play it for personal reasons. That's right. Okay, good. We agree. Conflab over. Conflab over. Conflab done. I think we should go back and take a peek into Dwight's interview. He's nude. He's in the break room. He has one underwear. I'm sorry, he has on his green underwear, which is his favorite. His green tidy whiteies. Yes.
百分之百。奥斯卡是个出色的会计。他看到了凯文办公桌那边所有的账目不符之处，他一直在做记录以保全自己，并且随时准备好这个文件夹在需要时拿出来，但他从未想过会为了私人原因把它拿出来。没错。好吧，很好。我们达成一致。密谈结束。密谈结束。密谈完毕。我觉得我们应该回去看一眼德怀特的采访。他赤身裸体。他在休息室里。他只穿了一条内裤。抱歉，他穿的是绿色的内裤，那是他的最爱。他那条绿色的紧身三角裤。是的。
Yeah. Dwight is really upset because Iris Black says, you know what? We have found out that this paper is toxic. Dundramiflin paper is toxic. And Dwight's like, no, this is slanderous. And he says, I need a credible source. And guess what? Iris just happens to have the New York foreman,
是的，德怀特真的很沮丧，因为艾里斯·布莱克说：“你知道吗？我们发现这种纸是有毒的。邓德米弗林的纸是有毒的。”德怀特说：“不，这是诽谤。”他说：“我需要一个可靠的消息来源。”你猜怎么着？艾里斯正好把《纽约工头》的
Sandra Mick on the line. Jenna, this character is hilarious. Yeah. How did you come up with her voice? It's so raspy. You sound like you've been chain smoking for years. This was hilarious. With the minute you opened your mouth, I forgot.
桑德拉·米克请到了线上。珍娜，这个角色太搞笑了。是的。你是怎么想出她的声音的？太沙哑了。听起来你像抽了几十年的老烟枪一样。这太搞笑了。从你一开口说话的那一刻起，我就忘了。
I forgot about Sandra Mick. I hadn't seen this episode since it aired. And when Nelly throws this to you and then you open your mouth and speak, I was like, what? Lady I was as surprised as you were by the voice that came out of my mouth. Everybody in the room was shocked. You look surprised. You kind of do this thing with your hand where you go like, oh. Yes, I got some phlegm stuck in my throat when I went to do this and it created this weird
我把桑德拉·米克这事给忘了。自从这一集播出后，我就再没看过它。当内莉把话抛给你，然后你张嘴说话时，我想的是，什么？女士，我对从我嘴里发出的声音感到和你一样惊讶。房间里的每个人都惊呆了。你看上去很吃惊。你做了一个动作，把手抬起来做出这样的手势，哦。是的，当我准备这么做时，有些痰卡在了我的喉咙里，从而创造出了一种奇怪的
raspy voice. The script did not specify any accent. It just said Pam speaks voice passably disguised. It was very disguised. I would never know that was you or Pam. The paper is not toxic. Unless it's exposed to oxygen, then it's very toxic. Which at the same time, I thought was very quick for Pam. I was like, oh, that's a good point. Dwight was believed that. Yes. Jim is going to barge in and tell Dwight that their stock prices are plummeting. Yes. And Jim says, you know what? Do we need to get someone who understands the media? And Dwight says, get out, get out of the room. Their little tussle in the break room cracked me up.
沙哑嗓音。剧本没有指定任何口音。它只是说帕姆伪装了声音说话。这伪装得太彻底了。我绝不会知道那是你或者帕姆。纸是没有毒的。除非接触到氧气，那样的话它就会变得非常有毒。与此同时，我觉得帕姆的反应太快了。我想，哦，这是一个很好的观点。德怀特居然相信了这一点。是的。吉姆气势汹汹地闯进来，告诉德怀特他们的股票价格正在暴跌。是的。然后吉姆说：“你知道吗？我们需要找一个懂媒体的人吗？”德怀特说：“滚出去，滚出这个房间。”他们在休息室里的一番扭打把我逗乐了。
And see, this is the thing. These are the early days of the office for me. Well, there was a really fun moment while all that was happening in the background, which was pointed out by Lauren W. From Alberta, Canada, and Emily M. from Brisbane, Australia, who said that they loved that in this scene, if you look in the background, Kevin is eating a snack and he
你看，这就是重点。对《办公室》而言，这是我加入的早期日子。嗯，当背景里发生这一切时，有一个非常有趣的时刻，由来自加拿大阿尔伯塔省的劳伦·W和来自澳大利亚布里斯班的Emily M指出，她们说她们喜欢在这一场景中，如果你看背景，凯文正在吃零食，而且
has also removed all of his clothes. Yes, I saw that too. I loved it. Such a fun detail. I feel like the minute he walked in, Dwight is like this, like snapping at him, like, take it off, take it off, take it off. You're going to stay, if you're going to be in here, you got to take all that snapping at him, like, take it off, take it off, take it off. If you're gonna stay, if you're gonna be in here, you gotta take all that off.
他也脱掉了所有的衣服。是的，我也看到了。我太喜欢这个细节了。我觉得他一走进来，德怀特就像这样，冲他大吼大叫，就像，“脱掉，脱掉，脱掉。你要呆在这里，如果你要呆在这儿，你得把这些——”冲他大吼大叫，就像，“脱掉，脱掉，脱掉。你要留下来，如果你要呆在这儿，你得把所有的衣服都脱掉。”
Yes, exactly, exactly. Well, next up, Aaron and Andy, they're going to the marina. Oh, yes they are. They had a bunch of driving sequences that we filmed that didn't make it into the episode. In one of them, they sing a song, and it's very clear that Andy has taught this song to Aaron.
是的，没错，没错。好吧，接下来，艾琳和安迪，他们正前往码头。哦，是的，他们去了。他们拍了一堆开车前往的镜头，但没有剪进正片里。在其中一个镜头里，他们唱了一首歌，很明显安迪把这首歌教给了艾琳。
Let's hear it. There's New Canaan, New London. It's where we get our fun done. There's Westport and Southport. A lot to fill your mouthport. And what's that in my daybook? Don't forget old Saybrook. And those are the towns of Canada.
我们听听。有新坎南，新伦敦。这是我们找乐子的好地方。有韦斯特普特和绍斯波特。能塞满你嘴巴的地方可不少。我记事本里那个是什么？别忘了老赛布鲁克。这些都是加拿大（注：原文如此，实际为康州地名）的小镇。
Cut. Oh, punch buggy, flu. No more punch buggy. Is that so funny? It cracked me up, but that's what they were singing on the way to the marina. And no more punch buggy, lady. I hated punch buggy.
卡。哦，痛击车，取消。不再玩痛击车了。是不是太搞笑了？把我逗得前仰后合，但这就是他们在去码头的路上唱的歌。而且再也没有痛击车了，女士。我讨厌痛击车。
I don't wanna get punched in thegy. I don't want to get punched in the arm. I don't want to. Erin really likes it and she really punches auntie. I hated that game. I also didn't enjoy hitting people. It just, it wasn't the game for me. I remember it from childhood. Well, when they get to the marina, Andy's boat is truly magnificent.
我可不想胳膊挨揍。我不想挨揍。艾琳真的很喜欢，她狠狠地揍了安迪。我讨厌那个游戏。我也不喜欢打人。这，这实在不是适合我的游戏。我从童年起就对它有记忆。好吧，当他们到达码头时，安迪的船真的是气势恢宏。
It's so much bigger and more beautiful than Aaron had ever imagined. Yeah. Aaron says, wow, this is how his family came to America. Yeah. They came on this boat. As they approach the boat, there's a man, a very grumpy man who's loading items onto the boat. And he, uh, this is Andrew Santino. And he has a line that is my favorite line from maybe the whole episode. Oh, tell me. He says, I'm not a ghost, so I can't walk through
比艾琳想象的要大得多，也美丽得多。是的。艾琳说：“哇，他的家人就是坐这艘船来到美国的。”是的。他们就是坐这艘船来的。当他们靠近这艘船时，有一个人，一个非常脾气暴躁的男人正在把东西搬上船。而他，呃，这就是安德鲁·桑蒂诺。他有一句台词是我可能整集中最喜欢的台词。哦，快告诉我。他说：“我又不是鬼，所以没法穿墙而过。”
people. He's so grumpy. He's so grumpers. A couple of things about this scene at 13 minutes and seven seconds, you can see a man in the background with a black hat. That was Kelly Cantley's sailing buddy, Jeff Sharlin. He was our like background actor on the dock. You see him here and then you also see him at the end of the episode, he helps them cast off at the end as they're sailing away. Now I asked Steve Burgess when they got out there, was there a problem at all in shooting like with people noticing that here's John Krasinski and Ed Helms and Ellie Kemper and Josh Groban on the dock?
人们。他太暴躁了。他脾气太糟糕了。关于这个场景有几件事，在13分07秒时，你可以在背景中看到一个戴着黑色帽子的男人。那是凯利·坎特利的航海伙伴杰夫·夏林。他是我们在码头上的背景演员。你在这里能看到他，然后在这一集的结尾也能看到他，当他们解缆起航时，他在最后帮助他们解开缆绳。现在我问史蒂夫·伯吉斯当他们去到那里时，拍摄过程中有没有遇到什么问题，比如人们注意到约翰·卡拉辛斯基、埃德·赫尔姆斯、艾莉·坎珀和乔什·格鲁班就在码头上？
Like that's a powerhouse group right there. production was pretty contained and we had actually rented the boat slips around the boat that we were shooting on and we used those to store our equipment and all that kind of stuff. So in our immediate area it was all us, but there were some people who were on top of a hill nearby who were just gathered and watching, but they didn't interfere at all. But there was something that greatly interfered with the shooting all day long. Can I guess? Yes.
就像那是一群实力雄厚的明星阵容。制作工作其实控制得相当好，我们实际上租下了我们正在拍摄的那艘船周围的船位，我们用它们来存放我们的设备以及诸如此类的东西。所以在我们紧邻的区域，全都是我们自己人，但附近的一座小山上有几个人聚集在那里观看，不过他们一点也没有干扰拍摄。但有一件事极大地干扰了整天的拍摄。我能猜吗？是的。
Seagulls? Not seagulls. Sea lions. Oh, sea lions. There was a group of sea lions that would not stop barking. Oh, oh, they're so loud. Yes. And when I was trading messages with Andrew, he mentioned them as well.
海鸥？不是海鸥。海狮。哦，海狮。有一群海狮叫个不停。哦，哦，它们太吵了。是的。当我跟安德鲁发信息时，他也提到了它们。
He said the biggest challenge about shooting this episode was not the boat. It wasn't anything like that. It was these sea lions. And you can't, it's like something that happens when you're shooting a show. Like let's say you're shooting at a house and then the person next door decides to get out their leaf blower. You walk over, you have someone walk over and be like, Hey, do you mind doing this another time? And, you know, here's a hundred bucks.
他说拍摄这一集最大的挑战不是船。根本不是那些。而是这些海狮。而且你没法，这就像你在拍摄一部剧时发生的事情一样。比如说你在一个房子里拍摄，然后隔壁的人决定拿出他们的吹叶机。你走过去，让某人走过去说，“嘿，你介意换个时间做这个吗？然后，你知道的，这里有一百块钱。”
It's actually very common. People purposely get out their leaf blowers and lawnmowers so that they can get a little hundred bucks. So, but you can't slip a sea lion a hundred bucks or like throw them some fish. I don't know what you do to make them be quiet. I don't know. I think if you throw them fish, they're just going to come back and say, Hey, I want more.
这其实非常常见。人们故意拿出他们的吹叶机和割草机，这样他们就能赚到一百块钱。所以，但是你不能塞给海狮一百块钱或者向它们扔一些鱼。我不知道你该怎么做才能让它们安静下来。我不知道。我觉得如果你向它们扔鱼，它们只会回来然后说：“嘿，我还想要。”
Yes, exactly. So that was the biggest challenge of shooting out on the boat. Well, Andy is feeling very nostalgic. He tells Aaron when he was a kid, it was his job to raise the main sail. And Aaron says, Oh, I wish I could have seen that. So Andy is like, okay, and he starts to raise the sail. And here comes grumpy sailor man. Says you gotta stop that.
是的，完全正确。所以那是在船上拍摄时面临的最大挑战。好吧，安迪感到非常怀旧。他告诉艾琳，他小时候的工作就是升起主帆。艾琳说：“哦，我真希望能看到那一幕。”所以安迪就说：“好吧”，然后他开始升帆。暴躁的水手来了。说你得住手。
Yeah, he keeps smacking Andy's hand. Every time he tries to raise the sail, he smacked his hand. I asked Andrew if he had a most memorable moment while he was shooting this episode, and he actually mentioned this scene Here's a clip. I Did mess up. I was so nervous. I messed up a few times
是的，他一直拍打安迪的手。每当安迪试图升帆时，他就拍打他的手。我问安德鲁他在拍摄这一集时有没有什么最难忘的时刻，他实际上提到了这个场景。这是一段剪辑。我确实搞砸了。我太紧张了。我搞砸了好几次。
I smacked Ed Helms with the wrong hand blocking the camera like an idiot and I did it about three or four times and I think Krasinski laughed it off and Helms was very cool about it. Everyone was very nice But they could tell I was green and I was a scared I was a little scared because it was a big deal. But that was memorable that I kept screwing up and Ed Helms was being patient. But every time I did, another bead of sweat would drop down my forehead and the makeup would have to run in and dab it down because I think I was just, I was a little nervous. And I was so hot in the sweater because in the basement of the boat there in the hull as it were
我用错误的手拍打埃德·赫尔姆斯，像个白痴一样挡住了镜头，我大概做了三四次，我想卡拉辛斯基一笑了之，赫尔姆斯对此也表现得很酷。每个人都非常友善，但他们能看出我还是个新手，而且我很害怕，我有点害怕，因为这是一件大事。但那段经历令人难忘，我不断地搞砸，而埃德·赫尔姆斯非常有耐心。但每次我这么做时，又一颗汗珠就会从我的额头上滚落下来，化妆师不得不跑过来把它擦掉，因为我想我当时只是，我有点紧张。而且穿着那件毛衣太热了，因为在船的地下室里，也就是船体里
Yeah, it was piping hot and there was there's no AC or anything But I was warm. I think we shot it in the fall. Maybe I don't really remember Unfortunately because of alcohol, but I was very warm. Well, I can tell you why you were warm We were filming in September, which we all know is our hottest month here. But you said it was only 76 degrees. 77 was the high. But, you know, if you're in the hull of the boat with no air, I'm sure that feels like with a heavy little sweater on. 88. 88 degrees, yeah.
对啊，里面热得像蒸笼一样，又没有空调什么的，但我还是觉得热。我想我们是在秋天拍的。也许吧，老实说我真的记不清了，因为酒精的作用，但我当时确实很热。好吧，我可以告诉你为什么会热。我们是9月份拍摄的，大家都知道这是我们这里最热的月份。但你说当时只有76华氏度。最高是77度。不过呢，如果你在闷热的船舱里，没有空调，我敢肯定那感觉，再加上一件厚点的小毛衣，得有88度。88华氏度，是的。
That's true. Well, Andy has not been allowed to raise the sale, but I guess Grumpy Sailor Man is going to let them have lunch down below deck. We got a very interesting fan question from Julia D in Redmond, Washington, who said, when Andy and Aaron are eating lunch on the boat, the pickles on Andy's sandwich have been taken off. Does Ed Helms not like pickles? Or was this a character choice? Julia, I'm so glad you asked. I went back to the script. The top of this scene was deleted.
确实如此。好了，安迪不被允许升帆，但我想暴躁的水手先生打算让他们去甲板下吃午餐。我们收到了来自华盛顿州雷德モンド的茱莉亚·D的一个非常有趣的粉丝提问，她说，当安迪和艾琳在船上吃午餐时，安迪三明治里的酸黄瓜被拿掉了。埃德·赫尔姆斯不喜欢酸黄瓜吗？还是这是角色的设定？茱莉亚，我很高兴你问了这个问题。我翻看了剧本。这场戏的开头部分被删掉了。
Here are the two lines that were cut. Aaron says, it's cozy in here. Andy, grumpy, says, these little pickles are gross. So I guess the scene started with Andy picking pickles off his sandwich. There's a tongue twister. Picking pickles. Picking pickles off his sandwich. Mm-hmm. Erin is trying to cheer him up again. She says, you know what? You don't have to sail the boat in order to be a man. As far as she's concerned, he's the captain. This gives Andy an idea. He wants to take over the boat. He wants to be the captain. He wants to
以下是两句被删掉的台词。艾琳说，这里真舒服。脾气暴躁的安迪说，这些小酸黄瓜真恶心。所以我想这场戏是以安迪把三明治里的酸黄瓜挑出来开始的。这还是个绕口令呢。挑酸黄瓜（Picking pickles）。从三明治里挑酸黄瓜。嗯哼。艾琳又在试图让他高兴起来。她说，你知道吗？你不需要为了当个真正的男人去开船。在她眼里，他就是船长。这给了安迪一个主意。他想接管这艘船。他想当船长。他想
take the boat to the Bahamas. And he's like, look, dude, keep your deposit, leave the supplies. But also I want that sweater. So lady, this sweater was like a second character in this episode. We got so second character in this episode. We got so much mail about this sweater. First of all, Johnny A. from Seattle, Washington said, I have waited an embarrassingly long time
把船开到巴哈马去。他说，听着，老兄，押金你留着，物资留下。不过我还想要那件毛衣。天哪，这件毛衣在这集里就像第二个角色一样。我们收到了好多关于这件毛衣的第二角色在这集里。我们收到了好多关于这件毛衣的邮件。首先，来自华盛顿州西雅图的强尼·A说，我等了一个极其漫长的时间
to ask this question. I have no good reason to know this, but the sweater that Andrew Santino is wearing, which Andy compliments and wants to buy, is the exact same sweater that Brock Love It wears in the Titanic. What? It's in the scene when Old Rose is telling her story to the crew.
来问这个问题。我没有任何充分的理由知道这一点，但安德鲁·桑蒂诺穿的那件毛衣——安迪称赞并想买的那件——和《泰坦尼克号》里布洛克·洛维特穿的完全是同一件。什么？就是老年露丝在向船员们讲故事的那场戏里。
If you go go Brock Love It, you will see it. I need that side by side. Oh lady, I've got it for you. Three mugs and two side by sides is what I'm about for this episode. Here it is. What do you think? I mean, it looks very similar. I also feel like I've seen the sweater on Ed Sheeran.
如果你去搜布洛克·洛维特，你就会看到了。我需要把这两张图并排对比一下。哦天哪，我都为你准备好了。这集我准备了三个马克杯和两组对比图。就是这个。你们觉得怎么样？我是说，看起来真的非常像。我也觉得我好像在埃德·希兰身上见过这件毛衣。
Yes. This must be a type of sweater. You know, like there's like a cable knit sweater or there's like a something knit or something not. The Fisherman sweater. Yes. Yes. But it looks like the same sweater to me. So yes, Johnny A. from Seattle. I agree. Also Tyler B. from Port Townsend said, I hope you guys can ask Andrew Santino if he really took that sweater. Well I did ask him, Tyler.
是的。这肯定是一种特定款式的毛衣。你知道，就像有麻花针织毛衣，或者别的什么针织毛衣之类的。渔夫毛衣。没错。是的。但对我来说它看起来就是同一件毛衣。所以，是的，来自西雅图的强尼·A。我同意。还有来自汤森港的泰勒·B说，我希望你们能问问安德鲁·桑蒂诺，他是不是真的把那件毛衣拿走了。好吧，我确实问过他了，泰勒。
He did not keep the sweater. He's bummed about it too. Yes, he's bummed about it. But I did ask him what was the response from him being on the office. And here's what he said. Many of people have reached out and said, you're the meanest guy ever on the office. So I obviously did a good job. People hate me because of that.
他没有留着那件毛衣。他也为此挺沮丧的。是的，他挺沮丧的。但我确实问了他参演《办公室》之后的反响是什么。他是这么说的。很多人联系我，说你是《办公室》里最坏的家伙。所以我显然干得不错。人们因为这个而讨厌我。
So I did a good job being a mean bully. That was the whole gig. I got some hate from the office die-hard fans online. But it was hate love. They loved because they hated me. They loved that they hated me. And it was so fun and a wonderful experience. I'm sad I didn't get to work with you. Obviously,
所以我成功扮演了一个讨人厌的恶霸。这就是整个差事。我在网上收到了一些来自《办公室》铁杆粉丝的恨意。但这是又爱又恨的恨。他们因为恨我而爱我。他们喜欢去恨我的感觉。这真的很有趣，是一次绝妙的体验。我很遗憾没能和你们一起演戏。显然，
you're the most talented actor on the show by a landslide. Second to Angela, of course, who is more talented than you. I should have said that first. I don't know why I did it in that order, but it was a privilege and an honor to be a part of it. And now I'm a part of history. And it's wonderful to have that in my resume for the rest of my life. And so yeah, I, uh, proud to be a little tiny blip on the, uh, historic Goliath that was the office. Hmm. Thank you, Andrew. I know, Andrew.
你是剧里最有才华的演员，可以说是遥遥领先。当然安吉拉除外，她比你更有才华。我应该先说这个的。我不知道为什么我按这个顺序说，但能参与其中是我的荣幸和特权。现在我也成了历史的一部分。在我的余生里，简历上有这一笔真是太棒了。所以，是的，我，呃，很骄傲能成为《办公室》这个历史巨兽身上，一个微不足道的小插曲。嗯。谢谢你，安德鲁。我知道，安德鲁。
There you go, Angela. You're the most talented. Thank you. I know. The second most talented. That made me chuckle. You guys, Andrew was so kind and wonderful sending these clips while he was on his cross-country drive. We don't know that for sure, maybe in airplane.
给你，安吉拉。你才是最有才华的。谢谢。我知道。我是第二有才华的。这让我忍不住笑出来。各位，安德鲁人在进行跨国自驾游的时候，还这么贴心、这么棒地发来这些音频片段。我们不能百分之百确定，也许是在飞机上吧。
He's going somewhere. You're traveling, Andrew, in our minds, and we are going to share your podcast and our stories. Thank you so much for taking the time to share your experience on the office. Yes. You know, his podcast with Bobby Lee called Bad Friends, they're currently on tour. You can go to their website, badfriendspod.com to get tickets. Canada, they're coming your way. Arizona, Las Vegas, badfriendspod.com. Thank you, Andrew. We'll put that in stories. Yeah, I'll do a swipy. Back in the conference room, things are heating up. Iris Black is reporting that the Greenwich police have surrounded the home of a despondent David Wallace. I guess he's taken the mailman hostage.
他在去某个地方的路上。安德鲁，在我们的想象中你在旅行，我们要分享你的播客和我们的故事。非常感谢你花时间分享你在《办公室》的经历。是的。你知道的，他和鲍比·李主持的播客叫《坏朋友》，他们目前正在巡演中。你可以去他们的网站 badfriendspod.com 买票。加拿大，他们要来你们那儿了。亚利桑那州，拉斯维加斯，badfriendspod.com。谢谢你，安德鲁。我们会把它发到快拍里。好的，我会做一个滑动跳转。回到会议室，情况正在升温。艾瑞斯·布莱克报道说，格林威治警方包围了沮丧的大卫·华尔斯的家。我猜他把邮递员扣为人质了。
Jim is going to play the chief of the police department, Bill Jackson. Dwight is begging them to take mercy on Wallace and he's going to call David himself and conference David in. Yes. Pam, Nelly, Daryl and Jim are like their expression at this moment of like, oh my god, he's calling David Wallace? And he does! He gets David Wallace on the phone.
吉姆要扮演警察局长比尔·杰克逊。德怀特恳求他们对华尔斯网开一面，他甚至要亲自打电话给大卫，把大卫三方通话拉进来。是的。帕姆、奈莉、达里尔和吉姆他们的表情此刻就像是，哦天哪，他要打电话给大卫·华尔斯？他真的打了！他把大卫·华尔斯叫到了电话上。
He's like, David, are you okay? He's like, David, are you okay? He's like, yes, I'm okay. Dwight is telling him like, I believe in you. I know you can make the right choices. Let the mailman go. Let the mailman go. David doesn't quite know what's going on, but he's like, thank you Dwight for calling me.
他说，大卫，你还好吗？他说，大卫，你还好吗？大卫说，是的，我很好。德怀特告诉他，我相信你。我知道你能做出正确的选择。放了邮递员吧。放了邮递员吧。大卫不太清楚发生了什么，但他还是说，谢谢你打电话给我，德怀特。
Please don't call me on my cell anymore. David Wallace always has the best responses. Like if anyone wanted to show receipts on him, he was appropriate. And to the point, and nothing more. Well, this ends the radio show. And it ends this whole drama. Dwight emerges into the bullpen.
请不要再打我的手机了。大卫·华尔斯的反应总是最棒的。如果有人想找他当面对质，他的回应总是既得体。又切中要害，不多废话。好吧，这结束了广播节目。这也结束了整场闹剧。德怀特走进员工办公区。
Everyone is chanting for him. Victoria, he saved the day. Amazing. Dwight has a talking head where he says overall this first radio interview went pretty much as he expected. That's about how he thought it would go. Good Lord. You know, back on the boat, Aaron is a little bit concerned. Is Andy really capable of sailing this boat for 10 days? By himself. And he tells her, listen, you know what?
每个人都在为他欢呼。维多利亚，他拯救了世界。太棒了。德怀特有一段单采，他说总的来说，这次电台初采访基本符合他的预期。这跟他想象的发展差不多。天哪。你知道，回到船上，艾琳有点担心。安迪真的有能力独自驾驶这艘船10天吗？他自己一个人。他对她说，听着，你知道吗？
I know how to hoist the sail. I can use all those buttons. And I know where the booze stashes. And he opens the door to find Walter Jr. Passed out with all the booze around him. Yep, and he says, Walter Jr., you're gonna be my crew. We're gonna have some serious bro time.
我知道怎么升帆。我会用那些所有的按钮。而且我知道酒藏在哪个地方。结果他打开门，发现小沃尔特不省人事地躺在地上，周围全都是酒。没错，他说，小沃尔特，你来当我的船员。我们要好好享受一段男人的时光。
They're the Nard bros. So that seals the deal. It's gonna be Andy and Walter Jr. They're setting off. Aaron is left back on the dock. The boat is floating away. Andy calls out to Aaron. I'll see you in three weeks. And then Walter Jr. starts playing the guitar
他们是纳德兄弟。所以事情就这么定下来了。将由安迪和小沃尔特同行。他们要启航了。艾琳被留在了码头上。船正缓缓飘走。安迪冲艾琳喊道。三周后见。然后小沃尔特开始弹吉他。
and he's playing the beginning to more than words. And Andy goes, them's McCards. And that's the last thing he says to Aaron. And this is when you can see that the boat is actually named Aspire 2. I think that might be why we had to cut that earlier Andy talking head. Oh yeah, because the name isn't the same. The name does not match. You know, Kelly Cantley said that Ed had to take a lesson in boat handling so that he could motor away from
他弹的是《超越言语》（More Than Words）的前奏。安迪说，这可是麦卡德的歌。那是他对艾琳说的最后的话。这时候你可以看到这艘船的名字其实叫“渴望2号”。我想这可能就是为什么我们不得不剪掉前面那个安迪单采的原因。哦对，因为船名对不上。名字不匹配。你知道，凯利·坎特利说埃德必须接受船只操控的课程，这样他才能把船开出。
the dock. It really is him driving. I saw this in the call sheets, lady. It said that Ed and Josh Groban both had to go to like a little sailing instruction. Yeah. Kelly said this was not uncomplicated because they had to have a big talk about the predicted wind direction, the sun position and time of day that they would be motoring away from the dock. And all of these things figured into when they shot this particular moment because they wanted Andy to sail in a good direction for camera. You know, they had to be sure that he would be lit. Well, what was in the background? All of it was so little. Mom, yes, so much planning.
码头。这真的是他在开。我在通告单上看到了，lady。上面说埃德和乔什·格罗班都必须去参加一点航行培训。是的。凯利说这并不简单，因为他们必须详细讨论预期的风向、太阳位置以及他们开船离开码头的时间。所有这些因素都考虑进去了，当他们拍摄这个特定时刻的时候，因为他们希望安迪能朝着有利于摄像机拍摄的方向航行。你知道，他们必须确保光线充足。好吧，背景里有什么？所有这些都是如此微小。天哪，是的，有这么多的计划。
Well, Erin is going gonna have a talking head. You know, she's happy she could help Andy, which she have liked to have gone maybe on a cruise to the Caribbean with him. If she asked, yes, that would have been fun and romantic. She's clearly stung a little that she did all this work to cheer him up and he just ditched her and went off once again.
好了，艾琳要有一段单采了。你知道的，她很高兴自己能帮到安迪，她难道不想跟他一起去加勒比海度个假吗？如果她开口的话，是的，那会既有趣又浪漫。她显然有点隐隐作痛，因为她做了那么多工作来让他高兴，而他却抛下她，再次独自离去了。
Well, we have a hot take to discuss. Oh, I love a hot take. Is it a spicy take? Is it spicy and hot or just hot? Just hot take. Oh, okay. It's from Jess M. in Virginia. Okay.
好了，我们有一个犀利观点要讨论。哦，我最喜欢犀利观点了。这是个辛辣的观点吗？它是又辣又犀利，还是仅仅很犀利？仅仅是很犀利。哦，好吧。这是来自弗吉尼亚州的杰丝·M的观点。好吧。
Jess says, Aaron says she would have loved to have been on the romantic boat trip with Andy. However, Andy clearly said that he needed time bonding with his brother, and his brother clearly needed it too. Their family has just imploded, and he and his brother have never had a good relationship, so them needing a long time to bond is not a bad thing. I know that this is supposed to be one of the examples of Andy being a bad boyfriend, but I stand by it not being a bad thing for him to not take Aaron. So
杰丝说，艾琳说她很乐意和安迪一起去进行那场浪漫的游船之旅。然而，安迪明确表示他需要时间跟他的兄弟培养感情，他的兄弟显然也很需要这个。他们的家庭刚刚分崩离析，他和他的兄弟从来没有过良好的关系，所以他们需要很长一段时间来培养感情并不是一件坏事。我知道这本该是安迪是个糟糕男友的例子之一，但我坚持认为不带艾琳并不是一件坏事。所以
Jess doesn't think that Andy was obligated to invite Aaron on this trip. What do we think? Well I agree with Jess that these two brothers have just been through a lot. And they probably both need each other right now. And I think that's a good thing. I just think once again, Andy doesn't finesse things well. He didn't have a moment where he was like, Hey, thanks so much. I've seen how hard you've been trying to cheer me up. And the idea to come to the boat was yours and this was so great.
杰丝不认为安迪有义务邀请艾琳参加这次旅行。我们怎么看？我同意杰丝的看法，这两兄弟刚刚经历了这么多。他们现在可能都很需要彼此。我认为这是一件好事。我只是觉得，安迪又一次把事情处理得不够圆滑。他没有抽出时间说，嘿，非常感谢你。我看到了你一直在努力让我高兴起来。来船上的主意是你的，这真的太棒了。
And I love you, but I'm hurting and so is my brother. And I think we need this time together. And I hope you understand. Yes, I agree. If he had just said that, you know, because I think the fact that he's going on this trip with just his brother is totally appropriate. But he did it very selfishly and like very self-centered. He didn't consider Aaron's feelings in any of it, which is why he's a bad boyfriend. Loretta But again, if you and I wrote these episodes, they would be like a dramedy. Yes, we'd have these big relationship monologues. I know. Exactly. Well, back at the office, Kevin comes back to their little desk clump,
我爱妳，但我现在很受伤，我兄弟也是。我想我们需要这段在一起的时间。我希望妳能理解。是的，我同意。如果他当时那样说的话，你知道的，因为我认为他这次旅行只带上兄弟是完全合情合理的。但他做得非常自私，而且以自我为中心。他根本没有考虑艾琳的感受，这就是为什么他是个糟糕的男朋友。洛雷塔，话虽如此，如果你和我来写这些剧集，它们就会变成一出悲喜剧。是的，我们会有这些盛大的情感独白。我知道。完全正确。好吧，回到办公室，凯文回到了他们的办公桌群，
and he says, Oscar, there's no promotion. Toby just wanted to update my personal information. Angela is very amused by this. She's very tickled at the idea that Kevin would even think he would get a promotion. And she's really rude to him and Kevin is about to fire back, but then who walks up? But the state senator. Mm-hmm. He had a feeling that someone that he loves needed attention today. And then he puts his hand on Oscar's shoulder and Oscar recoils like, ah, like he's been burned or something. And he's just like, what is that all about?
他说，奥斯卡，没有升职。托比只是想更新一下我的个人信息。安吉拉对此感到非常有趣。一想到凯文竟然会觉得自己能升职，她就觉得好笑极了。她对凯文非常粗鲁，凯文正准备反唇相讥，但谁走过来了？竟然是州长。嗯哼。他有一种直觉，觉得他爱的人今天需要关注。然后他把手搭在奥斯卡的肩膀上，奥斯卡像触电一样缩了回去，啊，就像被烫到了一样。他整个人就是，这到底是怎么回事？
And Oscar says, you know what? I'm just, I'm stressed out. Yeah. And Kevin is like, guys, guys, are we seriously going to sit here and just ignore the obvious? Oh, Oscar's face. So nervous. ignore the obvious. Oh, Oscar's face. Oscar's face. So nervous. And Kevin says, Senator Lipton has a big election next week.
然后奥斯卡说，你知道吗？我只是，我压力太大了。是的。凯文就说，伙计们，伙计们，难道我们真的要坐在这里忽视这个显而易见的事实吗？哦，奥斯卡的表情。太紧张了。忽视这个显而易见的事实。哦，奥斯卡的表情。奥斯卡的表情。太紧张了。凯文说，利普顿州长下周就要大选了。
Guys, he needs our support, and he starts leading everybody in a chant of USA. It cuts to an Oscar talking head, and he says, you know, I have to say, I'm impressed with Kevin. Yeah. And then Kevin has a talking head, and he says, I totally forgot about the affair. Yeah, just for a few minutes. Yeah. There was an alt for Kevin's talking head in the candy bag alts and I want to read it. Here it is. Kevin says, okay, I made it through the day. All I have to do now is make it through tomorrow and then every day until the senator divorces Angela and comes out of the closet and resigns from politics.
伙计们，他需要我们的支持，然后他带头喊起了“美国，美国”的口号。镜头切到奥斯卡的单采，他说，你知道，我不得不说，我对凯文刮目相看。是的。然后是凯文的单采，他说，我完全把那桩外遇的事给忘了。好吧，就几分钟。糖果包里的废弃片段里有一个凯文的单采备选，我想读一下。就是这个。凯文说，好吧，我撑过了一天。我现在要做的就是撑过明天，然后是每一天，直到州长和安吉拉离婚，然后出柜，并辞去政客职务。
If he can do that by this weekend, that would be best. I hope he does that stuff tomorrow. That's great. Oh, those are both good ones. Well, Erin is going to return to the office. Why? Why did she come back to the office? Why didn't she just go home?
如果他能在这个周末前搞定那就最好了。我希望他明天就把这些事办了。太棒了。哦，这两个都挺不错的。好吧，艾琳要回办公室了。为什么？她为什么回办公室？她为什么不直接回家？
Why did she do this? Because she had to have a really cute interaction with Pete, who is still sitting at reception manning the phones. Why hasn't he gone home? I don't know. Well, we know why he's at front reception, and they have this cute little moment where he invites her out for drinks to pour Richards.
她为什么要这么做？因为她必须和皮特有一场非常可爱的互动，皮特仍然坐在前台接听电话。他为什么还没回家？我不知道。好吧，我们知道他为什么在前台，他们有一个可爱的温馨时刻，他邀请她去波理查兹酒吧喝一杯。
And she says yes. She says okay. Romance. Romance, new romance. New romance. We've been rooting for this one for a while. Well, there you have it everyone. That's the boat.
而她答应了。她说好。浪漫。浪漫，新的恋情。新的恋情。我们支持这一对很久了。好吧，各位，这就是本集内容。
A big thank you to Andrew Santino for sending in those audio clips and also to Steve Burgess and Kelly Cantley. And to you all for sending in your questions and comments, those great background catches. We just love them all. We hope you guys have a great week and we will see you next Wednesday with The Whale.
非常感谢安德鲁·桑蒂诺发来这些音频片段，也感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯和凯利·坎特利。还要感谢大家发来的问题和评论，那些精彩的背景细节捕捉。我们真的爱死这些了。希望大家都有美好的一周，我们下周三《鲸鱼》见。
I really like that one. See you then. Bye. Bye. I really like that one. See you then! Bye! Bye! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
我很喜欢那一集。到时候见。拜拜。拜拜。我很喜欢那一集。到时候见！拜拜！拜拜！感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。
Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲。我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。